interested in playing naughty Dog's
remastered version of the last of us but
not keen to fork out for it again never
fear Sony is looking into giving ps3
users a discount if they already own a
copy of the game I'm mark Walton and
this is a game spot news update speaking
on the PlayStation Blog Naughty Dog's
Eric manas Ellie said we're looking into
the business model for all this and
we'll post about this once we have input
from all regions not a guaranteed offer
them but at least it's on the cards The
Last of Us remastered edition due out
this summer gives Naughty Dog's critical
and commercial hit a lick of next-gen
paint as well as bundling in all of the
games DLC those sony has faced criticism
from some fans wanting to sell the title
for a full retail price on PlayStation 4
when the ps3 version isn't even a year
old next-gen upgrades were offered in
force by Sony last Christmas where
customers could download a digital ps4
version of last year's seasonal heavy
hitters such as assassin creed 4 black
flag and call of duty ghosts for a
reduced price if they already own the
ps3 version of the game willing to pick
up a copy of the Last of Us remastered
at full retail price or are you going to
hang on for a discount let us know in
the comments below and for more on the
latest gaming news keep it gamespot